so i'm a huge believer in hands-on
education
but you have to have the right tools
if i'm going to teach my daughter about
electronics i'm not going to give her a
soldering iron and similarly she finds
prototyping boards really frustrating
for her little hands
so my wonderful student sam
and i decided to look at the most
tangible thing we could think of
play-doh
and so we spent a summer
looking at different play-doh recipes
and these recipes probably look really
familiar to any of you have made
homemade play-doh pretty standard
ingredients you probably have in your
kitchen we had two favorite recipes one
that had these ingredients and a second
that had sugar instead of salt and
they're great we can make great little
sculptures with these but the really
cool thing about them is when we put
them together
you see that really salty play-doh well
it conducts electricity and this is
nothing new it turns out the regular
plato that you buy at the stores
conducts electricity and high school
physics teachers have used that for
years but our homemade play-doh actually
has half the resistance of commercial
play-doh and that sugar dough well it's
150 times more resistant to electric
current than that salt dough so what
does that mean what means if you put
them together you suddenly have circuits
circuits that the most creative tiny
little hands can build on their own
so i want to do a little demo for you
okay so if i take this salt dough again
it's like the play-doh you probably made
as kids and i plug it in
to two leads of a battery pack simple
battery pack you can buy them at radio
shack and pretty much anywhere else
we can actually then
light things up
but if any of you have studied
electrical engineering we can also
create a short circuit if i push these
together
the light turns off right the current
wants to run through the play-doh not
through that led if i separate them
again i have some light
well now if i take that sugar though the
sugar dough doesn't want to conduct
electricity it's like a
wall-to-electricity if i place that
between now all the dough is touching
but if i stick that light back in
i have light
in fact i could even add some movement
to my sculptures if i want a spinning
tail let's grab a motor
put some play-doh on it
stick it on and we have spinning
and once you have the basics we can make
a slightly more complicated circuit
we call this our sushi circuit it's very
popular with kids i plug in again the
power to it
and now i can start talking about
parallel and series circuits i can start
plugging in lots of lights
and we can start talking about things
like electrical load what happens if i
put in lots of lights and then
add a motor right it'll dim
we can even
add microprocessors and have this as an
input and create squishy sound music
that we've done
you could do parallel and serious
circuits for kids using this
so this is all in your home kitchen
we've
actually tried to turn it into
electrical engineering lab we have a
website it's all there these are the
home recipes we've got some videos you
can make them yourselves and it's been
really fun since we put them up to see
where these have gone we've had a mom in
utah who use them with their kids to a
science researcher in the uk and
curriculum developers in hawaii
so i'd encourage you all to grab some
play-doh grab some salt grab some sugar
and start playing we don't usually think
of our kitchen as an electrical
engineering lab or little kids as
circuit designers but maybe we should
have fun
thank you
you